[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros en esta oportunidad
reporteros en documental
comenzamos
la lucha contra todas las formas de
violencia contra las mujeres y niñas es
una política en la mayoría de países del
mundo pero no siempre surte el efecto
deseado y los procesos son lentos en
francia- el 80% de las denuncias por
este hecho son archivadas según la
inspección general de justicia de ese
país sin embargo las mujeres poco a poco
siguen rompiendo el silencio y el
gobierno busca reivindicarse en su
esfuerzo por hacerle frente a este
flagelo cada año 220 mil mujeres son
víctimas de violencia física o sexual
por parte de su pareja o expareja y esto
hace que francia sea uno de los países
del continente europeo con las cifras
más altas de violencia de género un
hecho que el mismo presidente de manuel
macrón declaró el año pasado como la
vergüenza de francia- un equipo de
nuestro reportero siguió por un año a
cuatro mujeres que han luchado día a día
apoyando a las víctimas de violencia y a
sus familias desde diferentes
profesiones esta es la historia
[Música]
febrero de 2020 en los techos de parís
se prepara una operación comando para la
noche de la ceremonia el número 45 de
los premios césar
[Música]
cdp
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí no unas décimas
la operación como reacción a las
nominaciones del director roman polanski
acusado de violación y agresión sexual
fue interrumpida rápidamente
[Música]
que fue lo que pasó exactamente cuando
estábamos en el techo darle cuenta que
mucha gente nos estaba mirando cuando
estábamos en el techo y en un momento
dado había un viejo de [__] mirándonos
mientras hablaba por teléfono y cada vez
que lo mirábamos se escondía un rato y
luego volvía etcétera él fue el que
llamó al conserje e incluso a la policía
para adelantarnos pero lo que me choca
es que estoy segura de que si ese tipo
hubiera visto por la ventana a un hombre
golpeando a su esposa hasta matarla no
habría llamado nunca
no le incomoda a la mujer que es
golpeado pero si le pones pancartas en
la fachada se leen sucias y eso es lo
que no acepte su comodidad lo que tu
sigue entiendo muy bien lo que dices eso
es lo que es repugnante a mí no me
sorprende que alguien del edificio nos
haya de latasa
[Aplausos]
violación heridas secuestros
feminicidios la violencia contra las
mujeres está en todas partes y a menudo
comienza en la intimidad de nuestros
hogares si el hombre quiere la mujer no
hoy la obliga eso es una violación punto
estén casados o no cada año en francia
220 mil mujeres son víctimas de
violencia doméstica por parte de sus
parejas o exparejas
[Aplausos]
más de 150 son asesinadas detrás de las
estadísticas hay vidas familias que
quedan destrozadas
seguiremos ensuciando sus muros hasta
que la gente que nos gobierna haga algo
frente a esta violencia endémica mujeres
y hombres luchan junto a las
sobrevivientes para cambiar las cosas
isabel es abogada fabián es policía
louis el doctor yu ling es activista
cada una lucha en su campo para que la
violencia contra las mujeres deje de ser
inevitable la seguimos durante casi un
año
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y aquí está la historia de su día a día
apoyando a las mujeres
isabel este ayer ha estado luchando
junto a mujeres y niños víctimas de
violencia desde que prestó juramento
hace 27 años es la única abogada que ha
conseguido que el estado francés sea
condenado por negligencia en un caso de
feminicidio el de isabel tomas asesinada
con sus padres en 2014
el venido sitio su compañía y acababa de
dejar a su pareja quien no aceptó la
separación como suele pasar en los
feminicidios ahí es cuando se actúa
había intentado ahorcar la así que ella
fue a poner una denuncia en la comisaría
de su pueblo o comisariado y él fue
puesto bajo supervisión judicial con la
prohibición de verla e ir a los lugares
que ella frecuentaba en tus ojos sobre
new health and counting a pesar de estas
medidas su ex pareja patrick lemoa
seguía acosando la la seguía y le
enviaba cientos de mensajes
[Música]
isabel se refugió en la casa de sus
padres presentó varias quejas ante la
policía para denunciar estas violaciones
y una última queja en julio de 2014 su
expareja no fue detenido ni siquiera
convocado en agosto armado con un
revólver persiguió su auto asesinó a
isabel ya sus padres a plena luz del día
después de huir a bélgica fue finalmente
arrestado pero se suicidó estando
detenido lo que hizo imposible que se
llevara a cabo un juicio isabel esteller
demandó al estado por falta grave el
estado francés fue finalmente condenado
en abril de 2020
tanto en un juego de minis y la coleta
de face pero app una que hago el pozón
efe mini 7 liza
hay muchos feminicidios vemos que el
estado ha fallado en al menos el 40 por
ciento de los feminicidios las mujeres
ya habían alertado a la policía la
gendarmería y la trabajadora social
el médico cuantas quejas se necesitan
para evitar un asesinato en el caso de
tomás hubo cinco quejas
efe wapa el problema no es que las
mujeres tengan que hablar
isabel había pedido ayuda a pesar de que
estaba siendo perseguida la llamada de
auxilio fue grabada los disparos se
escucharon en toda la ciudad
también los escuchó la persona que
respondió a su llamada por qué no fue
enviada una patrulla de policía a pesar
de que estaba a 500 metros de la
estación de policía pues yo soy feliz
porque su interlocutor no le creyó
cereté hasta zometa y con saña
más que una longitud de la paz
la palabra de las víctimas es
constantemente puesta en duda según la
inspección general de justicia el 80% de
las denuncias de violencia doméstica son
archivadas en francia'
el primer paso el de entrar a la
comisaría sigue siendo el principal
obstáculo para la mayoría de las mujeres
la negativa a denunciar la minimización
de la violencia el hacer que las
víctimas se sientan culpables son
prácticas contra las cuales debió luchar
fabián hace ya diez años esta policía
creó cursos de formación para
concienciar a sus colegas
sabemos que puede haber deficiencias en
la recepción o procesamiento de ciertos
procedimientos hoy la policía hace un
examen de conciencia
hemos creado estos cursos de formación
precisamente para evitar todas estas
cosas que se dicen que pueden haber
sucedido no estoy diciendo lo contrario
pero estamos haciendo lo necesario y
todo lo posible para que no vuelva a
suceder
no sé a qué imagen tienen de los
policías a veces se tiene la imagen del
policía que es muy fuerte que no hace
esto lo otro y que habla con las
víctimas de manera muy distante para
protegerse de alguna manera pero también
se puede ser empática son que es la
primera persona que una mujer ve cuando
entra en la estación de policía tiene
que crearse ese clima de confianza tiene
que haber esa confidencialidad aunque no
sea física porque la recepción de una
estación de policía no es necesariamente
confidencial así que cuidado depende de
ustedes estar abiertos a hablar a
escuchar está prohibido estar en el
celular o reírse con sus colegas sin
prestar atención a lo que la persona
está diciendo eso toda una labor durante
estas sesiones trato de ser lo más
completa posible para que los colegas
entiendan lo que siente experimenta una
mujer es víctima de violencia doméstica
el hecho de que esté en el ciclo de la
violencia el hecho de que esté
controlada tienen que tener eso en mente
cada vez que estén frente a una víctima
de violencia doméstica con una vez han
oído hablar el hecho de que la mujer va
a venir a poner una denuncia y luego la
va a retirar
exacto
es un círculo vicioso porque ella cree
que la situación va a mejorar
está ahí la explicación está ahí todo
está ahí la atención las cosas no están
bien empiezan a empeorar vamos a tomar
el ejemplo de la violencia física porque
es el más claro llega la crisis es la
golpea al ruido los vecinos llaman o
ella misma llama a la policía es
transportada al hospital o no con una
denuncia si se acabó la relación ella
está cansada caricaturizó pero es más o
menos así y luego él regresa es cierto
que te golpee es verdad pero viste la
comida que preparaste honestamente
estaba fea trabajé todo el día y por la
noche llego a casa y es con lo que me
encuentro ponte en mi lugar
y la hace sentirse culpable así es se
justifica haciéndola sentir culpable y
después le dice te juro que no vuelve a
pasar vamos al restaurante vámonos de
viaje y ahí ella retira la denuncia
los policías son una de las pocas
profesiones que llegan a un domicilio y
a menudo son los primeros en ver la
violencia que ocurrió en privado pero
otros están en contacto con las víctimas
que se presentan por su propia voluntad
para buscar ayuda
al norte de parís la casa de la mujer
ofrece un programa de cuidado único en
francia este lugar fundado en 2016 y
respaldado por el hospital de sant de me
permite que las mujeres maltratadas sean
atendidas médica y psicológicamente y
que se reconstruyan socialmente
louis es interna en ginecología y
obstetricia y en medicina forense en el
hospital de gen no es una casualidad que
haya elegido la casa de la mujer para
realizar sus prácticas de seis meses
fuerte
[Música]
hace mucho bien
aquí unos 20 profesionales entre ellos
psicólogos parteras y sexólogos trabajan
juntos para ofrecer un programa de
atención integral para ayudar a las
mujeres a salir del ciclo de violencia
desde que se sentó me miró y me dijo
quiero que me ayude a escapar
suleman participe a la reunión de todas
las mañanas iba a la reunión de
personales con otros profesionales de la
casa de la mujer es un momento en el que
podemos discutir situaciones complejas
dificultades les damos consejos o
compartimos experiencias con otros
profesionales o dos profesiones quisiera
que las sacaremos de esa casa que la
lleváramos a ella ya sus hijos a otro
lugar ella me dice si no me proponen
algo estable prefiero soportar esta
violencia a desestabilizarlo todo así
que después de eso me dije a mí misma
maldición no podemos dejarla así y le di
una cita al día siguiente con matinal
excepto que la señora dijo no voy a
poder salir de la caja y aconsejamos que
le dijera a su marido que era para
buscar los resultados de los exámenes de
sangre o hacerse una prueba de kobe dijo
no me va a creer y al final no vino así
que la perdimos
no la perdimos me he estado destrozando
la cabeza para encontrarlo será que vale
la pena intentar hacerles llegar una
nota a través de la escuela hacerles
saber que puede volver si me llama este
lunes para darle una cita para el martes
era porque había todos los criterios de
peligro claro estrangulamientos incluso
le mostró cuchillos de cocina y le dijo
que la iba a matar violaciones casi
todos los días amenazas de muerte en fin
todas las alertas rojas era la primera
vez que le contaba a alguien no sé si ya
te haya pasado tener una mujer que te
cuenta 13 años de violencias por primera
vez en 30 minutos y luego desapareció
la violencia a la que se enfrentan estos
profesionales no se detiene sin embargo
cada día encuentran la fuerza para
enfrentar la brutalidad de estas
historias para ayudar
cuando pensamos en la violencia
inmediatamente pensamos en los golpes en
la violencia doméstica de hecho es mucho
más grande que eso hay violencia sexual
violación en el matrimonio violencia
económica violencia psicológica y nos
olvidamos de la violencia vinculada a la
mutilación genital femenina
recibimos mujeres que son víctimas de
mutilación a veces necesitan
certificados para solicitar asilo y a
veces piden una reconstrucción
quirúrgica porque se fue de mal y fue
por esta violencia
no es único
recuerda a qué edad de practicar una
decisión
si está de acuerdo vamos a ver la
decisión está bien
[Música]
voy a dejar que se quite el pantalón la
ropa interior y luego póngase justo aquí
puedo tocarse
quiere ver en un espejo conmigo
entonces para poder sostener el espejo
puede ver
recorrí karts y segura ciclista de
exilio
entonces la persona que le cortó el
clítoris tomó esto y cortó el capuchón
los labios menores y un pedacito del
clítoris esto se ve que el clítoris es
mucho más grande que el pedacito que
corto
también puede ponerse esta crema cuando
tenga relaciones sexuales se la pone en
su propio sexo es sobre el sexo del
hombre y eso va a evitar el roce así que
va a disminuir el dolor cuando ya no
haya dolor puede que sienta más cosas y
luego inténtelo usted ese siéntese
tranquila a veces se puede durar 15-20
minutos e intenté tocar ese punto para
ver si hay placer o no y si el dolor
persiste si no hay placer y quiere
trabajar en eso un poco puede venir a
vernos de nuevo de acuerdo si en
cualquier caso voy a prescribirle la
crema agria
la crema
a veces las mujeres piden una
reconstrucción no por la función sexual
o el dolor sino por una razón de
identidad necesitan recuperar algo que
les fue quitado necesitan hacer algo por
ellas mismas y pasar por un proceso para
demostrar que son capaces de hacerlo
para recuperar la posición de sus
cuerpos y su feminidad y esa es una
razón completamente válida para la
cirugía reconstructiva
no es muy humillante sentirse incompleto
cuando uno pasa al lado de otras mujeres
indicaciones de identidad clara
[Música]
la compañía la doctora gárate en todas
las semanas para aprender sobre la
cirugía de reconstrucción de clítoris
queda en temps ginecólogo obstétra es la
fundadora de la casa de la mujer
puedes darnos compresas por favor
pionera en el campo de la atención a las
víctimas de violencia ha sido una
inspiración para otras personas en el
quirófano es realmente una tutoría un
aprendizaje un acompañamiento ayuda a la
doctora atm que poco a poco me enseña
paso a paso y me ayuda para que pueda
ser autónoma después mi proyecto es
crear una estructura similar en el
hospital universitario de reina
en los últimos años las asociaciones el
personal sanitario pero también los
gendarmes y los agentes de policía han
entendido que deben trabajar juntos para
ser más eficaces
cuando intervenimos no somos médicos no
somos psicólogos así que no podemos
hacer ese trabajo los médicos no son
policías no pueden investigar y si no
sabemos lo que hace el otro no avanzamos
no vamos a ninguna parte
en 2020 en varios departamentos de
francia se firmaron convenios entre la
policía el sistema judicial y el
hospital para que se pudieran poner las
denuncias en el hospital directamente
las víctimas ya no tienen que ir a la
estación de policía no tienen que
enfrentarse a la mirada de los demás ni
tienen que contar su historia varias
veces
junto con las personas que lo hacen como
parte de su profesión las activistas han
elegido llevar la lucha contra la
violencia a las calles
japonés
efe municipales
soy una empapelado la del movimiento o
cola es feminista gay o que denuncia la
violencia contra las mujeres en los
muros
la idea es mostrarle a la gente que esto
sucede al lado de sus casas que no sólo
está en internet o en la televisión y
que no son un asunto de estado sino que
es asunto de todos
y le hace autobús
y lo es quien da la señal de partida
jolie es una de las que se comprometió
con la causa después del movimiento
michu en la víspera del día
internacional de los derechos de la
mujer participó en una manifestación
nocturna por primera vez rodeada de sus
amigos
es muy linda prefiero está el escogió lo
que quería poner
y
[Aplausos]
del año estar aquí de noche en la calle
con otras mujeres y decirles a todos los
que suelen movernos en la calle estamos
aquí ocupamos nuestro lugar y no tienen
elección ahora nos van a escuchar a
nosotras
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la reapropiación del espacio público no
sé si estamos en ese punto hoy
[Aplausos]
de todas maneras cuando veo los colas me
siento más tranquila por el camino y eso
les da fuerza a muchas mujeres
desde hace un año las que antes sólo
eran estadísticas y solo aparecían en
los medios de comunicación como un
suceso se revelaron en los muros de toda
francia
[Música]
pero algunas víctimas nunca llegarán a
ser parte de las cifras oficiales
y hay que ver los cognitivos
de macho septet julie fue encontrada
muerta su cuerpo estaba cubierto de
hematomas y su cabeza estaba desfigurada
porque le habían golpeado con algo
fuerte ya esta mujer la encontró 48
horas después su propia hija de 17 años
en ese estado rodeada de sangre en una
habitación que había sido completamente
revolcada que es que en todos los
participantes ya fueran los bomberos los
patólogos forenses que tuvieron que
pronunciar la muerte los socorristas
todos indicaron que hubo una
intervención de terceros susan y que fue
la hipoxia
límites al exterior cuesta trabajo
[Música]
aquí estamos
como la gran mayoría de los feminicidios
julie había recibido mensajes con
amenazas de muerte les había contado a
sus amigos y presentado varias denuncias
se añadieron muchas pruebas al archivo
de la investigación que consistía en
3000 páginas por ambas caras la hermana
de la víctima luz y tardó un año en
presentar una demanda civil por estrés
postraumático entonces se enteró de que
el magistrado a cargo del caso quería
cerrar la investigación
el baile tu vida
julie fue asesinada su hija la encontró
muerta en su sangre el 25 de junio de
2019 recibió amenazas de muerte de su
novio hasta las 11 de la noche antes de
morir a pesar de eso la justicia puso
fin a la investigación al concluir que
había sido una crisis mental
julie te queremos mientras no consigamos
justicia tendrán nuestra ira
siento que mi hermana me está enviando
una señal de verdad para decirme es lucy
tienes que seguir porque nadie vino a
quitar este memorial me dije que si no
quedaba nada me cansaría de luchar
porque estoy empezando a estar un poco
agotada aunque sólo llevamos un año
luchando y va a seguir así durante años
y ver que está completo me da ganas de
seguir luchando prueba que si la gente
no lo ha quitado no lo ha despegado
entonces quizás los ha conmovido y tengo
que seguir luchando para saber la verdad
que si le rompen un pastel en un parís
excelente proyecto
y ya no hay un número muy elevado de
feminicidios que los autores hacen pasar
por suicidios violencia que las mujeres
habrían cometido contra su propio cuerpo
accidentes domésticos accidentes hechos
no resueltos son éxitos aquí hay una
mujer muerta tal vez los autores del
crimen están en libertad por lo que
podrían cometer otros actos como ese por
lo tanto las mujeres están en peligro y
se detendría la investigación en un año
pregunto si un año es un periodo de
tiempo razonable para investigar la
muerte de una mujer y decir que más allá
de eso no vale la pena esa es la
cuestión es no vale la pena el juego que
te soy no te dan eso ya que está dando
de todas formas cuando abrimos el caso
nos dijimos que no había manera de que
ella se lo hubiera hecho a sí misma
tiene moretones por todas partes su
cuerpo está magullado y también está lo
de los dientes que perdió le faltan tres
dientes infligirse tales golpes así
mismo golpes que la hacen tragarse un
diente que termina en la faringe
mientras que los otros dos terminan por
a su cuerpo es bastante increíble e
impensable es imposible
amposta es un don que estamos en medio
de un caso que debería haber llevado a
investigaciones adicionales pero aquí no
tenemos detenidos no tenemos testigos no
tenemos nada no tenemos nada
y eso es lo que me preocupa cuáles son
las cifras ocultas del feminicidio es
esa estima que se queda y lusófono
adefemi visible
la violencia contra las mujeres no cesa
lo que es aún más preocupante es que con
cada crisis ya sea económica política o
sanitaria los derechos de la mujer
sufren un fuerte retroceso
la alerta de coronavirus
para protegerse y proteger a los demás
que deseen casa
[Música]
todo la playa ya confirmó una anécdota
y no como teléfono se le dijeron a tu
familia el oscuro imagine este confín ha
de crecer y feliz júbilo guanyar baile
durante el confinamiento hubo un
retroceso en los derechos de la mujer y
ante ello un aumento exponencial de la
violencia contra las mujeres y los niños
y cgt o cuando el marido estaba
confinado con la esposa había que
encontrar la manera de llegar a la
estación de policía
y cuando sólo una de cada diez
estaciones estaba abierta cuando las
unidades médico forenses funcionan
lentamente cuando los médicos no podían
ver la violencia porque estaban ocupados
con el cob y protegió como podían las
mujeres hacer una denuncia digna de ese
nombre y cuando finalmente querían pedir
una orden de protección no siempre había
magistrados y cuando llamaban al número
de urgencias el número siempre estaba
ocupado incluso a las dos de la mañana
decidí lanzarme a asociación que se
llama las bellas escapadas y
voluntariamente decidí poner mi teléfono
y contestar desde las 8 de la mañana
hasta la medianoche
de vista dos metas a mí ni me pregunta
si quiero que me vuelva a dar una
cachetada negrita esta situación es muy
seria pero hay que tener cuidado
aligerar la tensión porque esto podría
acabar en un homicidio la gestión
se puede ir si hay una agresión muy
grave dígame me ha pasado tener mujeres
en esta situación les dije que se fueran
y después recibí una llamada porque
habían sido asesinadas seguramente su
esposo va a sospechar si la ve mucho
tiempo en el celular le voy a decir que
borre los mensajes
veo que leyó los mensajes pero no
respondes si eso me preocupa
soy un portal con un tono y la visión
y dejase de mensaje
cualquiera que no sepa también quiere
[Música]
y yo recibí muchas llamadas los casos
más locos que uno se puede imaginar
incluso los niños me llamaban niños de
diez años que habían buscado el nombre
de un abogado en internet de internet
anotaba que si bien durante el
confinamiento se vio una disminución en
el número de denuncias presentadas en
toda francia las denuncias de violencia
aumentaron considerablemente
fabián se ofreció como voluntaria para
fortalecer la plataforma nacional para
la denuncia de la violencia sexual y de
género
tienes dos minutos si dime quería
hablarte de tu chat de anoche el de la
violación sufrí mucho porque ya no
quería decir nada en un momento dado
incluso dijo déjeme cuando ella fue la
que se conectó
se sentía que estaba muy reacia no
obtuve su identidad es una lástima
conseguiste que confiar en ti eso fue
bueno afortunadamente ella tenía tiempo
y yo también en contraste las buenas
palabras es algo bueno de esta
plataforma es una de las muchas
herramientas de las que disponen las
víctimas para evitar ir a la estación de
policía por miedo a no ser escuchados o
comprendidas la víctima entra en la sala
para explicar su historia se hace una
denuncia y se envía a la estación de
policías territorialmente competente y
la víctima es llamada por un oficial de
policía que le da una cita no tiene que
contar su historia varias veces la
diferencia con otras plataformas de
llamadas es que en esto solo hay
policías que está disponible los siete
días de la semana las 24 horas al día
buenas noches sargento mayor del portal
de denuncias de violencia sexual y de
género la llamo porque tengo un usuario
en línea que reporta que un padre está
amenazando con mandar a la madre ya tres
hijos de 16 14 y 11 años todos ellos en
casa de portazos golpea los muebles y
amenaza con enviarlos a todos al
cementerio 29 muchas gracias
siempre se da prioridad a las
emergencias es decir si una víctima no
puede llamar al número de emergencias
porque no puede hablar podremos llamar
de emergencia a los colegas con
jurisdicción territorial estoy hablando
con un caballero o una dama no sé qué
está preocupado por su amiga que esté
separada de su pareja que tiene dos
hijos y que amenaza con arrojarle ácido
y desfigurarse así que le sugiero que
haga un informe para que su amiga con su
ayuda pueda presentar una denuncia y que
se tomen medidas de protección para esa
persona
incluso si no hay una denuncia incluso
con una simple pensión de registro o
incluso con la intervención de los
colegas en el domicilio el fiscal puede
tomar medidas se dice que tiene la
oportunidad de influencia
es decir que puede asumir el caso de
abrir un procedimiento incluso si la
víctima se niega a presentar una
denuncia y hay que tener mucho cuidado
por supuesto con lo que se dice en el
chat porque no se sabe quién está detrás
de ellas no sabemos cómo qué intención
dicen las cosas no las podemos ver la
primera parte del chat siempre empieza
con poner a la víctima en confianza
los hechos que me están escribiendo son
graves son castigados y reprimidos por
la ley si se siente lista para presentar
una queja puedo guiarla y ayudarla con
el procedimiento no es una reacción
normal cuando uno fue víctima de una
violación puede confiar en nosotros sin
miedo no estamos aquí para juzgar sino
para ayudar no hay nada de lo que
avergonzarse se aprovechó de su
confianza
esta es la primera noche así de intensa
pero al menos fuimos útiles servimos
para algo espero pienso en que hay
muchas personas que se han puesto en
contacto con nosotros por lo que hay
muchas personas que están en peligro y
no me atrevo a imaginar cuántas están
confinadas en sus casas y no se atreven
a ponerse en contacto con nosotros o con
otros servicios de emergencia me molesta
que las víctimas no sepan todas las
formas en que pueden contactarnos y
obtener ayuda víctima con expertos y
fashion que les dónde probando el
contacto
obtener ayuda pero también aprender a
reconstruir su vida
en sand en y la casa de la mujer no sólo
proporciona atención médica
también se puede aprender a recuperar la
autoestima
[Música]
durante mis seis meses de prácticas
asistí a consultas médicas fui al
quirófano pero lo que realmente cambia
comparado con otros servicios son los
talleres que se les proponen a las
mujeres hacemos un movimiento preciso
tratando de sentirlo en el lugar donde
lo hacemos sentir realmente la situación
lo hacemos sin palabras y nosotros
tenemos que adivinar danza oriental
jardinería teatro aquí solo hay una
regla los instructores no saben nada de
la violencia que padecieron estas
mujeres su mirada se dirige hacia el
futuro
el taller de karate lo ofrece
gratuitamente una asociación llamada
fire for dignity lucha por la dignidad
así que lo que siempre les decimos a las
mujeres es que no es defensa propia no
se trata de pelear en realidad se trata
de tomar posesión de sus cuerpos
el sábado
les pido que toquen algunas partes de
sus cuerpos porque es complicado aceptar
que alguien les toque cuando han sido
abusadas por estas listas por ahí
ok tf1
2 sí y ahora que sea volvemos el pie si
usamos atrás
y um
no el otro el otro no pasa nada la otra
pierna la otra pierna si soñaba con
hacer karate desde quien es así pero
esta es la primera vez que tengo la
oportunidad de practicar me siento
fuerte en mi cuerpo me veo practicando
finalmente me siento protegida cada timo
ocasiones son potencias momento
vemos mujeres que al principio son muy
tímidas muy introvertidos con sus
hombros encogidos y poco a poco empiezan
a tener confianza
pude asistir al taller de autoestima
donde las mujeres hacen sus propias
joyas para hacerse algo a sí mismas a él
también se maquillan se peinan
[Música]
a mí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y sonreír de nuevo posar para una cámara
amar su imagen realmente volver a
apoderarse de su cuerpo y en sus ojos se
ve que están cambiando
[Música]
es un poco raro porque es el último
viaje de ida y vuelta a renault hace
cinco meses que hago viajes de ida y
vuelta sanden y ren ren shan de ning
para realizar estas prácticas que han
sido apasionantes y estoy emocionada
porque es también el comienzo de un
nuevo proyecto que es la creación de una
casa de la mujer en el hospital
universitario de repsol el objetivo era
duplicar este modelo en el hospital
donde trabajo y donde se interna en
ginecología y obstetricia así que es un
proyecto ambicioso que ha demostrado su
valor y es relevante en red y es cierto
que cuando eres un interno y tienes 28
años a veces no es fácil tener
credibilidad incluso si trabajas fuerte
incluso si tienes ambición pero
realmente creo que uno nunca debe
rendirse de lo contrario no se hará un
proyecto como éste hay que creer en ello
y creer en ello hasta el final
como nicolás ya de vez en cuando en los
escolares hay pequeñas frases añadidas
como el feminismo mata pero también hay
gente que las arranca hombres y mujeres
les molesta a leer esta violencia pero
esta violencia existe de washington y
asedió nos míseros heridos
[Música]
hay una frase que expresa muy bien lo
que queremos y es ya no queremos contar
nuestros muertos ya no hay nada más
claro que eso mientras que los que nos
gobiernan no hagan nada seguiremos
ensuciando sus muros hagan algo antes de
que todo a parís este cubierto de papel
a4
[Música]
todos están durante esta pasantía
descubrí que estaba embarazada de un
niño y eso me pone a pensar cómo se cría
un niño en esta sociedad patriarcal cómo
educar a un niño para que nunca sea uno
de los agresores cómo se educa un chico
cuando uno es feminista cómo darle su
lugar como le muestras que puede ser
muchas cosas y no necesariamente el
hombre que la sociedad quiere que sea
gracias ciencia no sé quindiana sufre
pin hace 1100 se asiste a tratar con un
feminicidio es prevenir la transmisión
de la violencia a través de las
generaciones proteger a las vivas y
honrar a las muertas dice un famoso
collage puede reducirse a una sola
ecuación c justo significa asegurarse de
que todas las denuncias tengan un
seguimiento que se trabajen como es
debido para que tengamos una respuesta
judicial satisfactoria para las víctimas
de la violencia doméstica o de toda
violencia contra la mujer
ahora elegimos a un reggae al
extraterrestre
el mensaje que me gustaría darle a las
mujeres víctimas es no duden hagan se
escuchar vayan a la policía a las
asociaciones es importante que puedan
estar acompañadas y él no tiene mensajes
para los perpetradores no piensen que
porque golpean a su esposa en casa no
iremos a buscarlos que no lo sabremos lo
sabremos y nunca los dejaremos en paz mi
sueño es que algún día ya no necesitemos
las casas de la mujer que las mujeres
dejen de ser objetos sexuales objetos de
poder objetos de manipulación mujeres en
venta mujeres para casarse cuyo jiménez
primordial es un gran proyecto
[Música]
i
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros
el documental recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web france24
puntocom para ver esta emisión y también
las anteriores hasta la próxima semana
[Música]